[Music]
when Janet takes her dog for a run on
the outskirts of Berlin she often sees
disabled people in the park recently
she's gotten to know some of them
[Music]
[Music]
this Center for the disabled has
provided a home to deafblind people for
more than a hundred years a century ago
it was far out of town today it's in the
midst of a prosperous suburb Janet
visits Oberlin house to find out more
about her new friends who can neither
see nor hear centers like Oberlin House
are generally built on the fringes of
cities and originally that's where we
were at the back of beyond you might say
but bobblesberg has grown up around us
and now we're in the midst of a suburb
we're served by trams and trains and can
get into town very quickly so we
confront society of course we protect
our people within a specific space but
we also empower them to live their own
lives for instance by giving them access
to a lot of normal things you know
Manatee television
normal things means in this case a
structured life and security discovering
that they're not alone in a world in
which their sight and hearing are
impaired for almost 140 years
Oberlin House has been a place for
people in need received support and
assistance this Christian service was
started by Jean Frederico baleen a
Lutheran pastor in a poor village on the
franco-german border there he organized
child care nursing and vocational
training following Oberlin's example the
Lutheran Church established a home for
the disabled on the outskirts of Berlin
Oberlin house the aim was to help the
crippled as physically disabled people
were called back then stand on their own
feet on January 14th 1887 a young girl
from Berlin came to Oberlin house a
child who could neither see nor hear
the deaconesses had never encountered
anyone with both disabilities at first
it was almost impossible to communicate
but hata shorts became the first
deafblind child in germany to be cared
for in given therapy many others would
soon follow by 1912 the original
building had become too small
more and more disabled people were
seeking professional help here the
center gained a reputation for
excellence the Deaconess is providing
care around the clock with therapy the
deafblind residents made striking
progress they learned skills and became
more independent
when this film was shot in 1926 anta
Schultz had been living here for 40
years she had learned sign language and
Braille managed household chores and
handicrafts and built up a collection of
small porcelain figures in dolls working
with deafblind people soon became one of
the core activities at Oberlin house
until the 1950s it was the only
institution of its kind in Germany after
this cheerful start little Tanya's day
begins with sensory perception exercises
Janet visits the group of Preschoolers
to which Tanya belongs during a therapy
session tamed at stimulating her senses
this is Tanya until Antonio wants the
vibration cushion that's your pets you
want some kissing ham take it sir let's
do you feel the vibration the education
is organized in a cozy environment and
in close cooperation with the parents
both in the daycare center and here in
the therapy section because one does
Kint filthy children start learning
immediately after birth parents talk to
their children but that's no use to a
deaf child the parents have to
communicate differently and they have to
learn how to do that as soon as it
becomes clear that a child's hearing or
sight is impaired special training
should start as soon as possible
dusty flu photos or not social Navy
Mukesh ions that smell again hey Nicky
do it Maggie no
Nick's mother brings him to the
educational group every day he has
charge syndrome a rare genetic disorder
that can affect various parts of the
body but especially eyes and ears Nick
Nick is making lots of progress because
of the therapy and that's always
encouraging that's keeping all my loyal
mood with early educational intervention
Nick can grow up to be relatively
independent in spite of his severe
disability I think when it becomes an
adult it'll be important that he's among
people like himself and is well cared
for that finish doesn't and because
oberlin house is so close to where we
live it will be our first choice we know
what it's like here other children know
Nick is our first but hopefully not our
last meanwhile tanya is training her
sense of touch with special exercises
hold your head up yes that's fun isn't
it look here you can look at it with
your hands your hands can also see yeah
yes
[Music]
first graders starting school
conveniently there's a school on the
Gobelin house crowns the second graders
put on a concert for the newbies
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the parents play an active role in their
children's education and as it any other
German school there are presence on the
first day at school
Tania will become part of a community
and will make friends
but her parents who have helped shoulder
her disability since birth
will remain the most important people in
her life
[Music]
yes inside attacking us it's the first
two or three days she was home we
thought it'll be a perfect family a son
a daughter the wedding but then
everything changed dramatically she
stopped feeding and had to be admitted
to the intensive care unit of the
Children's Hospital and they discovered
pretty soon that she was severely
disabled convulsions just imagine a
typhoon raging through your head
destroying everything the house
collapses you start to build up
everything again but if you're unlucky
and that happened to her the next storm
strikes and tears everything down again
so the mopping up operations in your
head are just very tiny steps we're just
happy that we're slowly finding our feet
as a family that tanya has found a spot
where she belongs but also that she
knows she has her place at home and that
will be for as long as she lives sublime
Tanya still has to get used to her new
environment school in this context means
further training of the senses learning
to feel and experience today while the
other children are in group therapy
tanya has the class teacher all to
herself Luke into skebawn
ruled on us I'm the heart in the Olympia
haneish may have a belt on I've
accidentally made us one of the children
who were born and brought up in a
hospital or an institution with little
or no contact with their families and
with the main caregiver constantly
changing to have very little confidence
in life - she could fix it doc fix that
fat cow inside not even though ideally
should I don't see at all they're much
less inclined to form relationships with
others that was never the case at
opening house disabled children were
given an intense education and they
learned together they had personal
contact with the deaconesses and with
other disabled children community was
important in every sphere
[Music]
is this guns which does a human have
it's very important that somebody
understands me but it's just as
important to have somebody who's fond of
me it's important for all of us and for
the children of course it's tremendously
important to have people in their lives
who love accept and appreciate them who
say to them you are important you are
okay the way you are all of us need
social recognition and goodies on the
first day of school the children are
still thinking about their holidays
which most of them spent with their
parents or caregivers what good
experiences did you have during the
holidays in a game
each of the children relates in his or
her way what they experienced the
children are at various levels of
development that's why they're often
taught individually but great emphasis
is placed on them having contact with
each other and on mutual assistance
holiday memories are grasped felt or
painted sensory perception and
communication are learned using various
methods and techniques
I'll check now to see if a sound comes
out in cooperation with research
institutes and with companies sponsoring
the lutheran church was able to set up
this modern acoustic laboratory it
enables staff to make a more accurate
assessment of hearing capability volume
pitch and directional hearing
[Music]
deafness is defined as more than 80%
hearing loss
modern medical technology can help
compensate for this disability other
forms of therapy involve less technical
expertise
Janet's curiosity was aroused by the
friendly encounter in the park her visit
to oberlin house coincides with a visit
by two dogs playing with the animals is
not just fun it increases physical
confidence its metabolites open the most
metabolites and open air givers have to
be prepared for a lot of physical
proximity in their work because it
functions by means of clear physical
signals people who have been deaf blind
since birth needs somebody to be close
to them they can't communicate over a
distance for instance I could now talk
to 200 people and they would all hear me
even if they were deaf I could
communicate with them in sign language
but deafblind people need me to be
directly in front of them I need my own
hands in the hands of my partner in
other parts of the body to communicate
sign language is a lifeline for deaf
blind people and this is how it works
[Music]
today even a severely disabled are
encouraged to do a lot of things for
themselves mr. Wolfe explains that he
would like to show the visitor his room
so we go yeah
mr. wolf suffers from asure syndrome and
was born deaf later he began to lose his
sight
now he's partially blind but in contrast
to people who were born deafblind he's
able to use the alphabet to communicate
they sell a fuse yeah mr. wolf is
thrilled that Janet understands what
he's written
[Music]
mr. wolf's neighbor mr. zipler has been
here for 50 years in spite of being
partially blind in death he loves
drawing which he does with passion and
skill
he draws from memory things he once saw
or things described to him over the past
few years he's painted hundreds of
pictures I think it's important to
emphasize that people with this
disability can live very contentedly
that there's a lot of activity in the
home that's that it's not just a place
where people are done I'm sole owner who
ever mentioned up used it throughout the
day a wide range of sensory experiences
are shared
[Music]
water provides a very special experience
swimming is an important aspect of life
at Oberlin house most disabled people
love the feeling of floating on water
and Janet realizes that year two in the
pool Trust is very important
yeah there's a feeler mentioned we have
many children and adults who love the
water they become completely different
people extroverted are completely
relaxed experience of being in the water
is generally very very positive janet is
impressed by the range of therapy this
institution offers
the following morning she visits the
Activa workshops in nearby pasta these
are also run by the Lutheran deaconesses
the workshops provide various forms of
employment for disabled people including
those who are deafblind
[Music]
[Applause]
mr. wolf also works here
his beautiful rat and chairs are an I
demand and commissions keep him busy
along with broom making and fabric
weaving wicker work has been a typical
activity of blind people for generations
exceptional finger skill compensates for
the lack of vision
the workshop has been looking forward to
Janet's visit
[Music]
she wants to visit mr. wolf at work and
it so happens that he's just finishing a
chair communication takes place with a
sign language called lawn mr. wolf
responds to show that he's understood
he's being told that Janet is happy to
be visiting him at work and he says he's
also happy
one sign sometimes means a whole word or
even half a sentence but you need the
manual alphabet to spell my name deaf
people have simple signs to refer to
each other but if I am introduced to
them we have to use the manual alphabet
there's a specific finger position for
each letter of the alphabet which
enables me to speak into the other
person's hand lorem is learned using a
practice glove the tactile alphabet was
invented in the 19th century by the
deafblind novelist hieronymus Lauren it
was taught from the beginning at Oberlin
house just like today there were regular
breaks and working hours and the same
sense of satisfaction at the end of the
day
[Music]
the bus ride home is also fun even if
everyone's already thinking about supper
[Applause]
[Music]
community meals are an important
activity marking the end of the Working
Day for carers and residents I enjoy the
work that's I try to communicate my own
experience of life I'm very active and I
want to communicate that we take part in
lots of events and we travel life is not
depressing it's full of fun which comes
from the residents themselves
I'm volumes harder DM dolphin evolve on
NVIDIA calmed demise anomalies proposed
for the most of the staff consciously
chose this profession they knew where
they wanted to work they did internships
during their training and decided that's
what I want to do I enjoy the work Bosma
we have a lot of laughs we're not
serious all the time we work with people
who have a hard struggle in life but
it's lively here on top statement is
bouncing even in the music group for
instance everybody participates as best
they can
listening here means using your whole
body it's not the sound that matters but
that everybody participates
[Music]
then Jarrah surprises everyone with a
spontaneous solo
[Music]
[Applause]
next janet plays Xena a visit
Xena shares a room with another young
woman in a block of three residential
units
she shows Janet the photos with which
she's decorated her walls the
residential units are a home away from
home and the youngsters regularly
receive visits from their families here
Xena takes Janet to the recreation room
their gatherings take place regularly to
foster a community spirit Janet knows
some of the others already general the
drummer for instance who's just finished
school most of the kids are sad that
their vacation is over what did you
enjoy at school theater on Mondays Xena
says reading and writing Zahra
on the other hand tells the group he
likes sleeping he's just turned 18
although his cyan't and hearing are
severely impaired he has the same
interests as any other young man
he shows Janet his favorite videogame
motor racing
Genaro wants to impress Janet then he
offers to buy her an ice cream Geron is
on the threshold of adulthood he's
learned to deal with his disability and
cope on his own and he'll soon move into
his own apartment and lead a perfectly
normal life
[Music]
[Music]